bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi elle 5
juillet focus sur deux saisons
culturelles celle de montigny le
bretonneux où se côtoient tête d'affiche
et spectacles plus intimistes et celle
de la batterie de guyancourt où tous les
styles se mélangent pour une saison un
rythme et nous retournerons à voisins le
bretonneux pour rencontrer à l'ail tribe
le groupe francilien clôturé la première
édition du festival la tour mais les
boîtes et nous irons aux yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole bertrand pin et vous
donnera conseils avec son coup de coeur
en plateau avec nous aller le voir jean
christophe archambault directeur de la
culture de métier le bretonneux et
stéphane ridard programmateur de la
batterie de guyancourt bonjour à tous
les deux alors on va commencer avec vous
jean christophe archambault
la nouvelle saison de montigny le
bretonneux et une nouvelle fois destinée
au grand public on y trouve des artistes
connus impossible tous les sites est
bien sûr mais a noté anne roumanoff qui
ouvre la saison vincent duclos ou encore
chantal ladesou tous les ans les c'est
de repartir sur ce tales tous les angles
et on essaie d'avoir une programmation
très généraliste très ouverte
effectivement avec des grands
rendez-vous à la le début de saison ça
serait avec anne roumanoff c'est ses 30
ans de carrière que vous avez cités
uniqlo on va retrouver le on essaie
d'organiser ça à la fois avec des
spectacles qui se créé assez récemment
et puis aussi des choses que des
spectacles ont eu un peu plus de
carrière déjà et qu'on apporte à nos
publics ici on est tout proche de paris
comment on arrive à faire venir des tels
artistes parce que ce sont des gens qui
font des grandes salles alors c'est vrai
que c'est c'est le principe est toujours
le même on repère ses spectacles lors de
leurs créations parfois un petit peu
avant et on est en rapport donc avec des
équipes les productions pour voir dans
quel cas dans pour s intégrer à leur
tournée puisque beaucoup de spectacle
commence soit par une salle parisienne
puis font la tournée soit l' inverse
et si dans ce cadre là qu'on met en
relation permanente avec les artistes
les productions pour essayer de
participer à ces tournées alors je le
disais dans les titres de grandes têtes
d'affiché des artistes un des spectacles
pendant un peu plus intimiste et
pourtant des artistes connus le prône et
c'est avec patrick timsit il interprète
un texte d'albert cohen oui tout à fait
c'est un projet qu'il dit avoir réfléchi
depuis déjà trente ans un projet qui me
tient énormément à coeur c'est vrai
qu'on le connaît timsit surtout pour un
aspect comique one man show où il a
participé à beaucoup de
deux films français aussi et là on est
sûr sur un rôle assez grave puisque
c'est une adaptation donc comme vous
l'avez du livre d'albert cohen qu'il
acquit qui rêvait de faire et qui là
qu'il a créée lorsqu'il a rencontré
dominique pitoiset son son metteur en
scène donc on est ravi d'avoir ce
spectacle est surprenant puisque même
dans ses rôles comiques on sait que
timsit est une espèce de force comme ça
un team has est toujours intéressante
donc donc ça sera une des premières
dates de sa tournée on est très heureux
de le retrouver sur ce texte là vous
teniez aussi à mettre en avant brasseurs
et les enfants du paradis
alors le nom va parler parce que sur
scène alexandre brasseur fils de claude
brasseur et petit fils de pierre
brasseur alors pourquoi cette pièce
alors j'ai découvert cette pièce à
l'automne dernier g j'y suis allée comme
ça en sachant pas très bien ce qu'est
l'être ce projet là et j'ai été très
étonné d'abord par le la performance
d'alexandre brasseur ou donc là on a une
rencontre de génération
comme vous l'avez dit fils petit fils
etc puis le sujet quand même une espèce
d'hommage comme ça à son grand père qui
a été commis dans ce film est donc c'est
un seul en scène aussi qui m'a vraiment
impressionné puisqu'il incarne tous les
tous les personnages qui ont fait
l'histoire de ce film qui fait vraiment
partie de notre patrimoine donc carnet
réalisateur trauner les décorateurs
cosma la musique et il raconte à peu
tout ce qui s'est passé quand ils
étaient tous réunis dans cette maison de
france pendant l'occupation
avec toutes les questions que ça pouvait
poser à réty aussi été dans le film les
gens étaient plus ou moins dans des
situations différentes par rapport à
cette situation particulière est donc
l'enjeu et qui est réussie et très
intéressant de faire revivre tout ça est
sûre sur un sujet qui reste d'actualité
aujourd'hui comment on se positionne
quand on fait du spectacle
quand on crée quelque chose quand on se
rencontre avec la diversité des uns et
des autres et un troisième spectacle va
falloir aller vite on n'a plus beaucoup
tous les deux on va regarder un extrait
d'abord c'est les châteaux et andrea
bescond mise en scène par eric métayer
regardes et tu te fais tu es fragile
encore blue tilt matin d'antenne râteau
ton
que devient pas trop invisible caché
derrière tous ces joggings mal
mon là
[Musique]
e
même
les chatouilles un spectacle et au sujet
fort ça parle notamment de maltraitance
de l'enfant
oui tout à fait rien que l'extrait alors
c'est plus un clip qu'un extrait c'est
pas un extrait du spectacle mais je
trouve quand on a vu le spectacle
redonne cette émotion là l'art là ça
fait partie des spectacles qui sont des
vraies découvertes il a une belle
carrière déjà il a commencé dans une
petite salle au petit montparnasse où
pendant deux ans il a tourné il a été à
avignon pendant deux ans et derrière il
a fait deux fois le châtelet il l'a
remplie et et voilà il laisse personne
indifférent il laisse personne intacte
il est très particulier est vraiment
exceptionnel dans le sens où
effectivement c'est un spectacle
biographique en drive est ce qu'on a
connu cette maltraitance
elle en fait un spectacle elle en fait
un spectacle de combat c'est une
danseuse dans ce absolument
extraordinaire donc qui qui fait théâtre
avec la danse ce qui lui permet
d'incarner une série de personnages
enfin encore une fois on était une
seconde c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui est
sur scène donc qu'ils arrivent à faire
sur ce sujet très grave un spectacle
très drôle très touchant très émouvant
et et voilà je suis très heureux de
pouvoir le faire découvrir aux
spectateurs il y monte à présenter
quelques spectacles bien sûr on n'a pas
tout dit alors pour découvrir le reste
de la saison culturelle
rendez vous sur le site internet de la
commune on passe à une page musique
maintenant avant de parler de la
batterie on part à voisins-le-bretonneux
puisque le 1er juillet c'était la
première édition de la tour mais les
ouates le nouveau festival de la commune
la tête d'affiche alec trappe
regardez
[Musique]
puis
un mélange de saveurs des pays du monde
de saveurs musicales
la recette alive drive group de natural
trance ont fait partie maintenant d'un
courant parce qu'au début a light rail
c'était un des pionniers de la natural
trance mais après d'autres groupes aussi
se sont joints à ce mouvement et ça crée
aussi un flot de musiciens qui sont
intéressés à la musique moderne à
l'électro un peu aux tchèques ce que
représente l'électro à réadapter avec
leur digérer douleur guitare leurs
basses leurs instruments donc ça c'est
important à nos yeux de représenter ce
mouvement à l'origine de copains gags et
du dos très vite rejoints par quatre
autres artistes est une mosaïque
d'instruments au didgeridoo australien
sitar indien djembé et guitare
électrique
on a la chance en france on a pu
rencontrer plein de joueurs
d'instruments complètement d'hiver du
monde et donc on a on a pris un petit
peu ces instruments comme le djembé le
n'goni la kora le didgeridoo tout ça
maintenant c'est vrai que dans chaque
pays qu'on va visiter on s'intéresse un
petit peu à leur culture et aux
instruments qu'ils ont et on va essayer
de ramener par exemple en inde on a
ramené le sitar au début ensuite le site
à électrique à lectra n'en finit plus de
voyager plus de 500 concerts à travers
le monde
après voisins le bretonneux ils ont fait
leurs valises direction le japon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on reprend avec nos invités notamment
stéphane ridard de la programmation de
la batterie de guyancourt une nouvelle
saison éclectique encore pour rester
dans la dans la thématique justement
deux des dix ans parce qu'on a fêté nos
dix en un mois 2 au mois de mai donc on
essaye de proposer des styles musicaux
qui peuvent plaire à tous les publics
ces grands écarts parfois vous a fait du
rap vous avez du jazz de la chanson
française
toutes les musiques ces mêmes
la batterie c'est un pôle musique qui va
de la musique classique jusqu'au hip hop
en effet on brosse vraiment tous les
tous les champs tous les genres musicaux
alors la batterie a une particularité
vous faites des deux mi saison on en
parlera plus tard pour la partie de
janvier pour cette première partie de
saison il ya notamment un concert à ne
pas manquer le 14 octobre
girma beyene et un petit mot qui sera
accompagné d'un collectif parisien qui
s'appelle à calais wee b donc voilà
c'est un peu compliqué à prononcer tout
ça mais
germany nez c'est un vieux monsieur qui
a plus de 70 ans un éthiopien qui a fait
une pause pendant 25 ans et c'est
francis falceto qui fait les
compilations ethiopiques qui est allé le
récupérer entre guillemets pour le
persuader de remonter sur scène
et donc il nous fera le l'honneur de
venir jouer dans l'auditorium on va
sortir le grand piano et puis et puis
derrière donc ce groupe à calais betclic
qui a vraiment un groove très très très
très important très longtemps donc je
pense que les gens vont rapidement se
mettre debout à l'auditorium justement
pour donner envie je vous propose de
regarder un extrait
[Musique]
à la mairie
d'une cohérence
oui c'est victoria
c'est un régal
et à chaque date quasiment à chaque fois
une première partie notamment betty
bonifassi un petit mot oui alors betty
elle sera en première partie de charles
pasi qui a un français qui va sortir la
sonde album en septembre chez blue note
donc c'est plutôt une bonne référence en
termes de l'appel et betty elle devait
venir en avril sauf qu'elle a été
obligée elle vit au québec en fait elle
est niçoise mais elle vit au québec
depuis de nombreuses années et pour des
raisons de santé en avril elle n'a pas
pu assurer sa tournée européenne
donc on a décidé de leur proposer de
jouer en première partie de charles pas
ils sont un petit peu sur les mêmes
esthétique blues blues rock
donc ça c'est le 10 novembre il y avait
une deuxième que vous aviez mis en avant
quand on a préparé cet entretien laura
perry d'un qui scelle soir en première
partie de cock robin ces joutes fruits
alors c'est un petit peu le grand écart
parce que laura elle l'est plus tôt
repéré notamment par l'adami sur les
leur label talents jazz
donc elle passera cet été notamment à
jazz à vienne en première partie de souk
héros donc voilà c'est pareil ça me
contre les cards donc on s'était dit
pour la faire découvrir un maximum de
public
voilà les ouvrir pour coop robin qui est
plutôt dans une esthétique pop rock
alors qu'elle y avait il ya des nappes
cc1 parfois un peu électro
elle va aussi valeureux jazz univers
très particulier et 1
par moments on peut faire penser aussi à
bjork donc voilà c'est vraiment une
artiste à découvrir je pense que d'ici
quelques années elle devrait faire son
chemin artistique d'emmener sûr aussi à
la batterie vous aimez mettre en avant
les artistes locaux
il y à caso et coyote cette année oui
alors qu'un saut en fait il était venu
faire une résidence chez nous en février
par rapport à la sortie de son disque et
on lui a proposé
justement de faire un concert de
restitution qui était prévu au départ en
juin mais il partait tourné à l'île
maurice puisqu'il est il est franco
mauricien il fonctionne assez bien
là-bas à l'île maurice donc il sera chez
nous le samedi 7 octobre avec plein
d'invités
il est soutenu par tonton david
notamment donc tonton david viendra
aussi dans la liste d'invités qui qu'il
a vu un petit peu avec nous je crois
qu'il fera un set de 45 minutes je crois
à ton avis mais c'est vraiment juste
avant le set de kasso ses banques à ceux
qui terminent la soirée avec un certain
d'invités caporal nigga strike qui a dit
enfin un certain quelqu'un qui commence
on va dire presque commencent à
reconnaître c'est là déjà un nouvel an
dans le reggae dancehall caso même si
les résidents de guyancourt s'il habite
à guyancourt
il commence à être assez reconnus voilà
démarrage de carrière mais ça se passe
plutôt pas mal dans son sa famille
musicale et c'est pour ça que mon la
compagnie les voilà c'est il habite à
guyancourt donc il est logique que
l'équipement puisse être à disposition
aussi de c2c groupe donc coyotes moi je
vais proposer de jouer en première
partie de passy et de et sages poètes de
la rue puisque c'est au niveau du hip
hop c'est un petit peu ce que ce que
coyote défend on va dire le hip hop des
années 90 et là il ya un gros retour de
toute cette famille là avec l'âge d'or
du rap qui a rempli quand même quasiment
tous les signes de france et puis bercy
donc
donc là on va dire cette soirée hip hop
est plutôt consacré à des trentenaires
et quarantenaires qui vous ont passé un
petit peu alors leur jeunesse merci
stéphane bédard on a donné quelques
dates pour vous aussi pour voir le reste
bien sûr toutes les informations sur les
sites de la batterie et c'est la fin du
set 8 culture merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve à mercredi prochain
[Musique]